baroness Betty boothroid was bold bulshi
and a breath of fresh air when in 1992
she became the first female speaker
she was appreciated on both sides of the
house for her wit and no-nonsense
approach Madam Deputy speaker the fact
that
[Music]
which though wasn't her first Betty
worked as a high-kicking tiller girl
before turning to politics after several
attempts at the ballot boxes she became
an MP for West Bromwich in 1973. she
quickly Rose to become a widely
respected parliamentarian and then
elected speaker I wear a skirt rather
than pantaloons I don't wear a wig
because I want to feel comfortable in my
working outfit I've got to feel
comfortable like that but I have not
neglected the traditions of this great
office especially when upholding proper
parliamentary conduct I have no
alternative but to ask the honorable
gentleman for bolsover to withdraw from
the house she was not going to tolerate
any loudish behavior and I remember once
when Tony Marlowe MP shouted across the
chamber to me that I was a stupid cow
and she slapped him down immediately it
was a big mistake it's this shared
respect which MPS reflected in the
Commons it was heartening to hear a
northern voice speaking from the church
a voice that pierced through a man's
world in a formidable fashion in a
phrase you know so well but has never
been more true
time's up that was forever Betty
ashnaranag Sky News